normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this from The New York Times house
censures Jamal Bowman for false fire
alarm lawmakers voted to formally rebuke
Mr Bowman for setting off a false fire
alarm in the house office building the
latest partisan use of a once rare
congressional action forly reserved for
grave offenses uh rep crane what is
censure what does that mean yeah it's
just basically like a slap on the wrist
I mean it really it it's it's really not
not anything substantive I mean he's
going to yeah he's going to have
commercials run up you know by his
opponents that he was censured but it
really doesn't do much and it doesn't do
anything not really no it's offic it's
it's official it's the official way for
Congress to disapprove of you yeah he
had he had to go down to it happened
today I was you know there on the house
floor and he basically had to go down to
the well which is like right in front of
where the speaker chair is and you know
they they they read his censure and he
had to stand there publicly and all the
Democrats like crowded around him didn't
they all vote in support of him or
something yeah yeah the Democrats voted
in support of him but he did pull
obviously he pulled he pulled the fire
alarm pulled the fire alarm and uh I I
remember the day it happened and I
thought it was a joke when people were
telling me that he pulled the pulled the
fire alarm and it was kind of ironic and
funny that you know he was a principal
um he was acting like he did he he
thought it was like going to let him out
of the door or something he should be in
jail and I I think he should be expelled
from Congress I think cure is too light
let let me ask you why was why was uh uh
Santos expelled for being too awesome
but seriously though like like what what
was the actual offense he committed in
Congress that that warranted expulsion
yeah I I know he had a bunch of
indictments I didn't vote to expel him I
I voted to keep him um but I know that I
know that the New York delegation was
really pushing hard for him to go and
and this was just my theory it's just my
thought I think a I I think that a lot
of the New York constituents and donors
that got burnt by Santos were putting a
lot of pressure on those guys to get rid
of George now if you ever met George in
person like the guys he's hilarious um
I'm not going to sit here and defend
George's like Persona what he did what
did he do I I don't know well they they
said he used a bunch of campaign funds
to you know buy you know he broke a lot
of campaign fin laws like he used
campaign funds to like get bowo and get
like just a bunch of consumer goods and
services that you're not allowed not
allowed to do stuff like that um using
people's credit cards um that that were
donors to like buy stuff like that so I
he had a bunch of indictments yeah um
but yeah I mean serious but the my my
concern with it is though if that
becomes the standard right you're
indicted and then we can kick you out we
can kick you out of Congress because of
a report the Ethics Committee did in my
opinion that opens up uh you know a
pretty big door especially when we're
watching you know former president Trump
they're trying to do the same thing to
him they're trying to destroy him with
lawfare and indictments and so I don't
like the predent it's why many of us
tried to save George and we saved him
more we we saved him um in the past but
it because he's not convicted of
anything no could he be that's wild oh
yeah he can
and some of my colleagues I've talked to
some of my colleagues who are lawyers
and prosecutors who who do believe he
will be but I don't know man that's not
my I don't know that I don't know what
else that means I mean Trump will be
convicted I don't see a scenario in
which Trump is acquitted by by these
liberal juries I don't either but I
would think you would wait until a
conviction before you
expel which yeah which is why I think
many of us were trying to save him you
know but we know Jamal Bowman
intentionally pulled the fire alarm we
know he lied about it he's on camera
pulling the warning signs off the door
or he flicks one onto the floor and then
pulls the alarm and runs away he didn't
try to open the door he's he lied and
I'm I'm surprised that you can have a a
member of Congress commit a crime on
camera caught doing it to subvert the
political process and this is it he slap
on the wrist yeah if it was like at 4 in
the morning and he was pranking people
that would be different than if he was
doing it during a still a crime yeah but
now he was doing it during a
congressional Pro proing to try and
delay the proceeding like that's
Insidious well I don't know his intent I
assume it's to delay the proceeding but
did it delay a proceeding I don't know
that it delayed the proceeding and I I
heard that's what his intent was I don't
know exactly what his intent was but
yeah that's what he did he said it was
because he he was late and he needed to
get out the door or something yeah and
so he took the sign off the door that
said emergency exit well was funny cuz a
bunch a couple of my colleagues Andy
Biggs is in that same building
Congressman bigs and uh he went he went
to that exit uh along with some other
guy saw that there were they had already
cned it off and so they just went around
to a different in you know a different
exit um so it doesn't make a lot of
sense that that he did what he did but I
don't honestly I don't know why that
surprises you Tim I mean it's you know I
mean it's Congress
man you know Menendez has gold bars I
mean that's the it's like yeah that's
crazy the place is ripe with I was I was
a stuff I was hanging out at the uh
local Poker Room last week and someone
asked some guy said I'll make a bet with
all these older guys just out of the
blue goes I'll make a $20 bet with all
of you that he goes right now the
approval rating of Congress is
177% but all the 80% of Congress will be
reelected in 2024 and and uh uh well I
explained to him I was like well yeah
it's because we like our rep we hate all
yours so Congress has gun have a low
approval rating yeah but it but it is
funny considering nobody likes Congress
yeah just just approval rating in the
gutter everybody views it as corrupt I
don't like it either how many I I I
think I was I was talking to uh Matt
Gates and he said there's like how what
number did he give 10 or 12 good good
members of Congress or something like
that yeah it it's something like that
man it's pretty it's pretty small more
it's pretty small like how do you how do
you be considered good in Congress cuz
like obstructing kind of is your job but
if if you obstruct too much then are you
considered a bad guy yeah Thomas Massie
kind of gets that from time I'm
definitely I definitely fall under that
um I would say that that label if you
will but you're right it is tough
because you you don't want to obstruct
to the point where you can't get
anything done but at the same time when
I mean take pick a topic whether you're
talking about the Border whether you're
talking about the national debt 33
trillion plus in debt $2 trillion doll
annual deficit and what we do uh under
uh Republican control in this Congress
we made a deal with Joe Biden an
additional $4 trillion to the national
debt and so it's like it doesn't really
matter what topic you pick I I I think
that we're failing and you know so if
you're
obstructing that that type of failure in
in in my opinion you know I think we're
in Idiocracy right 100% the movie yeah
course they're watering the crosss with
Mountain Dew
uh with with with uh B Gatorade like
glyos to be honest is this Gatorade yeah
that was was it Luke Wilson it's what
it's what plants crave what plants crave
and uh he's basically salting the Earth
but I feel like we're actually in that
and the reason why is I I look at Jamal
Bowman and I'm like what a
scumbag and this is why everything's
broken this is why everybody hates
Congress this is why nothing's getting
fixed this is why we're having all these
problems well I should say it is a
component of I think I think we have
cultural issues yeah but I I look at so
so many of these members of Congress and
it's it's crazy to me that Jamal Jamal
Bowman pulled the fire alarm Jamie Rasin
falsely accused me of advocating for
January 6 in in the in the j6 hearings
yeah because I reported on a Fox news
story that Donald Trump called for
protests on January 6 so before January
6 happens I'm reading a news story from
Fox News where I'm like wow Trump's
calling for a protest that's going to
get crazy like things get crazy down
there if Trump calls for this yeah he
runs clips of me out of context included
in a montage of people screaming kick
the door and things like this right that
that that guy's 20 minutes from here
Rasin people who work at this company
are he represents them right I these
people I just look at them all they are
it it it is the dregs of humanity yeah
scum lying cheating stealing without a
care for anybody else they don't want to
make anyone's life better they want to
make their own lives better they want to
watch you know you know what they are
they are the people stealing the Fine
China from the Titanic knowing the
iceberg hit but they're going to get to
they're going to run to the the
emergency rafts before anybody finds out
the emergency boats yeah I often use
that same analogy I mean there's a lot
of problems with Congress but I think it
is important that we always remember
that like Andrew Breitbart said a long
time ago he said that politics is always
Downstream of culture yep so you never
even you don't see things get to the
halls of Congress until they've been
permeating in culture for a decade you
know 5 years at a minimum speeding up
though oh it is it is but and that's
that's how I feel a lot of time because
you know you'll sit there and you'll
just watch you know good Amendment or
this good bill go down and you're like
what the hell is going on here and I
think to your point Tim it is there
there is a certain level of that like
hey this type this this thing is going
down I'm going to get mine on the way
off right yep I I 100% believe that
there are Folks up there that that's
their mentality I think it's most of
them I got the vibe that it's there's
too many people for the representatives
to represent like how many people are in
your in your uh so most yeah most reps
rep about 750,000 people and it's like I
mean I represent myself I can't really
even represent Tim properly if I tried
cuz I don't I'm not Tim so like the idea
that back in the day the least worst
thing we could do is send some brilliant
guy to go represent the 7,000 of us and
hopefully he's going to know what we're
what we all kind of need and want in our
community but now we didn't it's it's so
un unrepresentative of the humans
because there's such a diverse desire
and belief within systems like I've had
this idea like what if we just everyone
gets the BET has gets like the power of
the House of Representatives now we all
can work from home we can all can write
legislation and pass it onto a system
where we can all read it and put
amendments and then after 30 days we can
all vote on it to pass it into the
Senate but we'd still vote for you guys
that if the power goes out you go to the
place to do it for us until the power
comes back on then we all get back to
work I think it's a bad idea and I don't
think it makes sense what do you think
about you like you know I like honestly
I I like that we have a constitutional
republic what I don't like is like you
you guys hear about the fourth branch of
government all the time the
administrative State the bureaucracy
right if you think about it there's a
bunch of unelected bureaucrats that are
in DC full-time they look at a guy like
me who comes in there and tries to you
know shake things up a little bit and
they're just like we can just wait this
guy out you know he has he has to get
reelected every 2 years and by the time
he gets the documents that we're
stonewalling him on right you know it's
it's so far it's so far into the future
that people are like oh move on that's
in that's in the past and so you know I
do like the fact that we have a
constitutional republic um you know but
there you know our system has problems
like everybody else and I think right
now the administrative state is one of
our biggest problems I I think one of
the biggest mistakes we made was the
17th Amendment so I think we should
repeal that that is the uh Senators by
popular vote I think that Senators
should have always been chosen by the
state legislator to represent the state
to the federal government so the the the
Kathy hoel when um Santos was actually
on the day he was he was uh removed or
whatever they voted for it Kathy oel
said that she was going to replace uh
what's his name and she obviously
doesn't have the power to do it and it's
be part of the reason why she assumed
that she did is because she doesn't have
a fundamental deep understanding of our
governmental structure she is the
executive of the state of New York
that's why and what the error that she
made is she was was thinking that she
should be sending the per selecting to
represent the the represent the people
for congress but she would select the
senator because the senator is supposed
to represent the state she would so
there's because she
misunderstands how the structure of
government works that's why she made
that error that's why she said oh I'll
select for the the house the people
obviously have to select who was going
to represent them in the Congress she
she would she would s oh we just we just
lost Phil Serge is doing some deep deep
trench right
now so uh I'll just I'll just pick it up
from there uh the the general idea with
the 17th Amendment uh uh was that it was
there was corruption that uh state
legislators were just picking their
buddies we can't have that that's a
mistake because now nobody cares and
knows who their state senators are and
who their state reps are and that's
substantially more important for
everything because if this country was
unified culturally to a certain degree
where everybody was paying attention to
their state reps and legislatures you
could get a Convention of States you
could actually have the states just be
like not we're changing things we don't
it's we're done with Congress we're done
with the Senate you're not getting
anything done and then there's other
ways to do it too amending the
Constitution through Congress and uh uh
through the Senate but we don't have any
of that right now and uh I think I think
you need it so I I look at this idea
that you're talking about Ian and it's a
huge mistake and it's for exactly what
you were saying you it could take you
years to get the documents you need and
you're fighting reelection every two
years and if you can maintain that you
can get these documents you Ian sitting
in your room waiting for a bill and
thinking you want to pass it bro we are
going to get people who are going to who
are going to think the polar bears are
dying and so they're going to vote to
build a polar bear Sanctuary it's it's
like the SS
when they built the bear Patrol you guys
remember bear Patrol one bear wanders
into Springfield one time and so they're
like okay everyone's panicking they all
voted for a referendum for the bear
Patrol and so then Homer looks at his
paycheck a week later and he sees a bear
tax and they've got like planes flying
around that's the problem with people
who I think that's why we have a
constitutional republic with
Representatives we we select the person
we think is the best for the job to do
the job like any other job and then we
trust they do the job well and if they
don't we fire them it could be that the
representatives maintain their Authority
and ability to like request documents
but that we just as Citizens gain an
ability to also produce legislation that
we can vote on together CU like I feel
kind of helpless a lot of times looking
at Congress and being like I have no all
I can do is convince people to go
convince someone to do something Have
you ever actually like written your
Congress person um no I would make
videos to and be like call them now call
call them at 2:00 everyone coordinate
make a phone and and just overload them
with phone calls I'll do that kind of
thing with the interet video but I never
actually did it myself um cuz I think I
mean the the you're never going to I
don't think anyone's ever going to feel
like the direct power of being able to
say or very few people are going to be
able to say hey I want this to happen
and then it happens right like that's
not like even the president doesn't
doesn't have that authority over
everything like there I I I don't want a
bunch of people voting on how to fix my
toilet no not at all I want people
voting on anything no my my toilet
breaks and then we're like okay
everybody we're going to we got a broken
toilet so let's put it on the internet
and everybody body all around gets to
vote on how we fix the toilet now I want
to hire a plumber who's the best of the
job yeah but what maybe I'm Mis
misrepresenting what I what I'm thinking
I just like is if you could make a bill
and be like this Bill gets funds for a
better process of toilet repair what do
you guys all think and it's like a
Tinder where people like I'll swipe
right on that one I'm swiping left I
yeah right right that's that's that's
that's like suggesting the community
vote on how to fix my toilet but then
well we would just vote on on a bill
that we could send to the Senate and
then the Senate would be like that's
idiotic no they shoot us down if it's
terrible like they do so so so you're
basically just saying you want to
eliminate Congress or I'm sorry
eliminate the house I kind of want a
legitimate fourth branch of government
I'm I'm just I don't think the
representatives can handle the load it's
too many people that they're
unrepresented the problem that you're
articulating isn't that there are too
many it's not that they can't handle the
load it's that the load that's being put
on the on the government is too great
for the structure of government so our
government is not supposed to be in the
daily working of your life the federal
government at least right so like the
fact that we have like that the fact
that there was ever a question about who
goes into which bathroom that was at a
federal level is a is exemplary of or
exemplifies exactly what our problem is
we don't need the federal government to
to make every decision for us you don't
even need the state governments to do it
honestly but that's where kind of that's
kind of how society's knee-jerk reaction
is become and I think really like no on
you're right on that point I think
that's a big part of the problem it's
like people have we you you've got I
think generations of people who have
been raised to think that federal
government is the solution and it's not
it's usually the problem and I don't
think our Founders wanted I think our
Founders I know they wanted limited
government because they they've seen
what it can do right and so you know I
think that's that's what some folks in
DC right now are trying to do um you
know it's why we fought so hard to
change out our leadership this year
because we we just continued to head
head down the same path that we were on
and you know like the fight we got back
into January I know you guys had Matt on
your show and you you you've had him in
the past I mean that that fight hadn't
happened what happened in January hadn't
happened in over 100 years this was
Kevin McCarthy yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at
timcast.net members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time